[拍手]
会社はそう国で見ていきましょうはい
と今日は自分に正直に生きたら幸せちゃうっていう話をしたいなというふうに思います
自分に正直に生きるっていうのはどういうことかそれは2つあると思います
一つはやりたいことに正直になること二つ目はやりたくないことに正直になること
でやりたいって思ったことに正直になること
僕は一つだけ自信があります僕はやりたいと思ったことだけは何でもやってきました
全部やってきた自信があります例えば
アメリカ横断を仲間としたりカンボジア
あすいません仲間とアメリカ横断をしたりこれはキャンピングカーであったんですけど
男女14人でみんなに会い紀香って言われたんですけど僕は全然声ができずみたいな
感じで
で僕はセドナっていうところが一番素敵なんですけどそこで僕が感じたのは
なんかしなんかようわからないんですけど自然と一緒に
均等あかんなあという様はからインスピレーションが出てきて本当にすごいんですよ
ぜひ行ってみてください
他にはカンボジアに小学校を建てに行ったりしました
これは
本当に仲間とアホなことをするために作った反対なんですけど僕に31人の家族が出来
ました
まぁこんな感じで僕はいろんなことをやってきましたとにかくやりたいと思ったら何で
もやる
そんな感じで今までやってこれました僕はすごい飽き性で何か好奇心旺盛だったから
本当にたくさんのことをやってきました
今日はやりたくないことに正直になるっていう4の話をメインにお話ししたいと思い
ます
僕はあ
やりたくないことにも正直です
皆さんは人生でこれまでもうここから逃げたいって思ったことはありますか
僕は数え切れないくらいあります大学から部活から人間関係からいろんなことから僕は
逃げてきました
ででも僕は逃げてきたんですけどでも今すごくやりたいことを見つけていてとても
すごい幸せなんです
世間的には逃げるのは悪いって言われてるんですけど僕的には本当にそうなのかなって
思うんです
逃げるのは必ずしも悪いことじゃないって僕は思うんです今日はそんなことをシェア
できたらいいと思います
僕は24年前ごく普通の家庭に育ちました
目を離すとどこかに行く子供だったらしく迷子になってもわかりやすいように
僕はいつもタケコプターのついた帽子をかぶって育ちました
僕は小中校は普通の公立の高校に通い
センター試験を3度つまり3浪して京都大学に入っています
僕の人生はまさに社会のレールに乗った人生でした
ちょっと乗れなかったんですけど
そして僕は兄弟ラクロス部に入ります
ラクロスというスポーツはご存じですかねぇ
史上最速の急ぎって言われてるんですけれども僕はこのスポーツにドハマリしました
うまくなるの楽しいし仲間も面白いし一緒に練習して癒さ
バイアスもう朝がめっちゃ速いんですけど毎朝一緒に練習して一緒にご飯を食べて言っ
て本当に青春みたいな日々を送っていました
でも僕は他の大学生とを見ているとなんかみんな楽しそうだなぁとか俺はなんでこんな
部活ばっかしてるんやろうと
ちょっと疑問が出てきたんですねそんな中ある時から僕は
なんかラクロスの練習がしんどくなってきたんです
なんか自分はもっとなんかいろんなことがしたいせっかく大学に入ったんだから
いろんなことをしたい二浪までして入ったんだからいろんなことがしたいって思ってき
たんです
そうやって他に各僕はやめて新しいことがしたいなって思いました
僕は逃げたんですラクロス部を辞めました
で
他のことがやりたくてやなことから逃げたくて僕はに入れたんです
でも
周りからはすごくダサいって思われてたと思います
でも僕はラクロス部に居続けるよりも自分は
他にいろんなことがやりたいそう思って僕は逃げました
でも僕は逃げて自由を手にしたんですなんか今までは何かやりたいなあと思っても
月あるしなぁ無理やなーって思ってたことが何でもできるやんって思ったんです
でいろんなことをやっていきましたいろんなことをやってまたいろんなことから逃げて
いきました
とにかくいろんなことをやって面白くないと思ったら逃げていってそういうことをして
いました
ん
で
こういうことをしていると大人の人はだいたいこう言ってくれるんです
続けた方がいいことあるよ続けないと見えないものもあるよっ
頭ではわかっているんですけど僕の心がそこにまでついていかなかった僕は続けた方が
入っての頭ではわかってるけど
ん
っていう感じだったりすると
僕は結構人生に時間人生には限りがあると思ってて時間を大事にしています
僕は常に自分の心に正直に生きたいってそういう生き方を僕は選択しています
でもこういう生き方をしていると悩むこともたくさんあります
僕はなんでこんなに何事も続かんのやろうとかなんでこんなにもすぐ飽きちゃうん
だろうとか
僕はほんまに社会で生きていけるのかなとか絶対就職とか無理やなってそういう悩みが
ありましたでも逃げ続けていった先に築いてきたことがあるんです
それは
逃げて僕はやりたくないことがわかってきたんです
いろんな経験の中で僕は単純作業が無理なことが分かりました
与えられた仕事が嫌なことが分かりました見下す人が無理なことが分かりました人を
幸せにできないことをやりたくないって思いました
やりたくないとか一緒にいたくないという人がわかってきたらおのずと自分がやりたい
こととか
自分が一緒にいたい人っていうのが分かってきたんです
もう一つ
逃げてきた先に自分の輝ける場所が見つかったんです
僕は特に変化してなくてもある場所ではあいつホンマに中途半端で何股も通過本学せ
られなって思われてるのにある場所では
ほんまにか知って何事にも興味があってほんまに面白い奴やなって人が態度を豹変する
んです豹変というか違うところに行ったら違う人の味方をしていて僕があんなに否定さ
れていたのに
僕をめちゃめちゃ肯定してくれる環境があったんですそうやって僕は何も変わってない
のに場所が違えば人は違う
味方をしてくれるんだということに気付いたんです
そういうそういうことがわかっていくうちに僕はどこ行ったら自分活躍できるかどこ
行ったら自分が人気者になれるんかっていうのに
いうのを探していきました
だから僕が思うのは
もしあなたが成果が出ないとかうまくが上手くいかないとかそういうことがあるのなら
それはあなたが悪いんじゃなくてもしかしたらあなたがいる環境があなたに合ってない
だけなのかもしれない
僕はそう思うんです
誰にでも輝ける場所はあると思うんです
誰かが輝ける場所を
作るために僕は学生団体をこれまで作ってきました
自分と同じように
この今既存の環境やったら輝けへんけど新しい環境こんな環境があったら輝けるって
いう人が僕みたいにいるんじゃないかなと思って
そんな環境をつくってきました次に紹介するのがその一つです
先ほど行ったカンボジアに小学校を建設するプロジェクトです
僕はこの団体を立ち上げたんですが
ちょうどこの夏学校みんなで現地に行ってコンクリート化を固める作業とかを全部
みんなでしながら学校食べてきました
でも正直僕はリーダーとか行ったことがなかったですすごい逃げまだからリーダーとか
向いてないんです
でも本当にしんどかったし本当に辞めたいし毎日履くような時期もあったんですけど
それでも僕は続けたい気持ちのほうが強かったんです
で僕は最後までやり抜くことができました
こんなこと初めてだったかもしれないです
で大人が今まで言ってくれてたように続けてきたら
続けて来ないと見えないものっていうのがあるって言うことを僕は知りました
しんどくて辞めたくても最後までやり続けて仲間の笑顔が見たかった
それが僕の夢であり僕の目標だったから
僕はこの経験を通して自分が仲間が輝ける環境を作るのが僕の夢なんだなって気づき
ました
大事なことはそれが本当にしたいのかっていうことなんだと思うんです
やりたいことをやってたら人は勝手に輝く c 1は勝手に集まってくるんです
僕たちはどうしても人と比べてしまいますでもそれはしょうがないことでもあると思う
でも人よりも良い収入とか人よりも有名な会社とかあなたがそれにワクワクできるなら
僕はいいと思う
でも本当にそれがしたいのかっていうのが重要なのではないでしょうか
やりたくなかったらすぐに飽きてしまいますやりたくなかったらなんであなたがする
のって思ってしまうんです
別にあなたじゃなくてもいいやんって僕は思ってしまうんです
これは僕の人生観やけど
僕たちは生きててよかったって最後に思えるために生きてるんじゃないかなって思うん
です
だから毎日後悔しないように生きよって生きていると思うんです
公開っていうのはやりたいことをやらなかった時に
するもんなんじゃないかなって思うんです
僕はやりたいことをやるって言うことが生きる意味なんじゃないかなって思うんです
やりたいことでないなら逃げてもいいって思うんです
いつのまにかどんな困難でも乗り越え
逃げずに立ち向かう人は正しいかっこいいってそういうふうに僕たちは洗脳されてきた
のではないでしょうか
逃げるのは開く逃げないのはかっこいい
ほとんどの人がそう思っているのではないでしょうか
確かにスポーツで成果を上げている人や歴史上の偉人というのはどんな困難も乗り越え
てきた人なんだ
乗り越えてきた人なんだと思います急いで僕たちがその人たちを見て感動しカッコイイ
と思いますでも僕がはもうにはその人たちはすごいけどすごくないって思うんです
やりたいことをやってるだけなんじゃないかなと思うんですやり
たいことをやっているから頑張れるんじゃないかなってそういうふうに思うんです
本当にやりたいことなら辞めたいって思ってても続けたいっていう気持ちのほうが強い
んじゃないかなって僕はそう思うんです
やりたいことが見つかるまでは逃げてもいいんじゃないかなって
僕は思うんです
迷惑をかけるのはいいことではありません僕もたくさん失敗してきました
でも誠実に正直に向き合ってたら案外人はわかってくれるもんだなということも知り
ました
生きてたら迷惑ぐらい書けると思うんです女はかけたらアカンってことはないと思う
すぎてたら迷惑ぐらい書けると思うんです
でも自分も命をかけるけどだからこそ人の迷惑もちょっと許してあげようって思える
人間になりたいんです僕は
迷惑をかけた分思いやりでカバーできるような人間が増えたらこの世界はもっと優しく
なるんじゃないかなって僕はそう思うんです
逃げることは悪いことじゃない
心がこれじゃないって叫んでいるのかもしれない
正直になりたいって叫んでるのかもしれない
僕の人生が輝きだしたのはいえから始まりました
すごくダサかったと思いますでも僕は
舞え舞え舞え舞え逃げ続けた結果
人はそれを挑戦って呼んでくれました
正しいことは僕は言えへんしこの世の中に対して正しいことがあるとは僕は思わない
ですけどでも僕は自分の心に正直に生きるって言うことでしか人は幸せはつかめないん
じゃないかなって
僕がこの23年間生きてきたこれが最善の答えですありがとうございました
[拍手]